Julie you have 33 producing credits
which of the films or film in particular
are you most proud of
hmm well I think I'm in a way proudest
of a series of films that that I
executive produce that came out of 9/11
when I was the chair of the Graduate
film department at NYU and it was a very
scary moment for me because I had
actually never taught before and I
taught when I was the chair of the
Graduate film department at NYU I taught
a class in producing and the first day
of the first class I said you all need
to get your database your address book
whatever it is get the names of
everybody in this class and keep adding
the whole time you're here because you
need people to make films and you never
know what you're going to need or when
you're going to need it but it's very
important to have a lot of people you
can contact so that was the first thing
I said and the second thing I said was
there's really only one question and
producer needs to be asking all the time
and that question is why aren't we
shooting and between the first class and
the second class 9/11 occurred why we
weren't shooting as the Giuliani shut
down film production everywhere in the
five girls so that was a problem and I
was really stymied for the first time as
a producer I don't know how to get these
students to shoot when it's forbidden so
I came back to LA on the weekend and I
thought about my database and I called
Jerry off say that who was at Showtime
then and I said Jerry I asked my
students at NYU - give me one visual
about something that affected them in
9/11 and I'd like to show you my
pictures and he elected them and he said
how about $100,000 for ten student films
to air next year on 9/11 and I think
that was a very high moment for me Wow
okay I didn't I didn't know the full
background of that and then the film's
did air a year they did anniversary okay
do you still keep in touch with any of
those filmmakers I hear from them all
the time will you read my script do you
know where I can get financing for this
and you know and some of them have kind
of gone into other walks of life and
they still stay in touch and one is
teaching and a couple of them were
teaching at other film schools and one
of them actually who was you know a
teaching assistant of mine when I was at
NYU was chinese-american and we just
shot a film last year in Guangzhou and
she went over to run production for us
that was a very nice moment one of the
students was a Chinese who had a
background in medicine and I knew of a
doctor who had been a who was very
familiar with a program in China in
which Khrushchev had said to doctors in
China I want you to put together the
best of Eastern and the best of Western
medicine so that in the Soviet Union we
will have the best of the best and this
doctor knew about all of these doctors
who had worked on that project and they
were getting on in years and he wanted
to document it so this student went over
and did the documentary film for him so
the first day of class would happen and
then do you remember when you heard the
news about the towers oh yes well my son
called and said this terrible thing is
happening you know right in the zone
this was you know NYU was very near to
where the towers were and where they
fell and it was early in the morning and
then we knew and everybody was reacting
how in you know in unexpected ways
because some people who I thought would
be very
tower of strength druid fell apart and
the others the reverse I remember I had
one student who who had been in
Yugoslavia and under in war-torn years
and the first thing he did was grab
bales and go for water so everybody had
a different way of coming at it yeah
I've heard that before that people that
seem maybe slightly off in some sense
actually fare better during a crisis
than those that seem like they would
handle any more
so then after Giuliani reopened the city
or you know it's been some time now I
don't remember the exact turn of events
how soon were you back in the class
again oh well the classes the class went
on over pas yes and in a very short time
we got an answer from Showtime I was
thinking I know the legal department at
Showtime I know the legal department at
NYU there gets good this is going to
take a long time but in a matter of a
couple of weeks everything was done
everything was sealed and the students
went forward with their you know coming
up with their projects and then Showtime
selected from those that were submitted
and we went forward and they got the
made and you know it was very heartening
you